and that's like the most important tip
that i want to give about this first
question is just like don't put such an
immense amount of weight on this very
first deal that you're doing because
believe me what you don't want to do is
screw up a partnership with your dream
brand
welcome to the think media podcast my
name is heather torres and i'm the host
of your show here where we're helping
you grow your influence on youtube and
then turn that influence into a high
impact and a high profit online business
and if you're new to the show i want to
welcome you and if you're returning and
part of our think media fam thank you
for tuning in week after week we drop a
brand new episode for you every single
tuesday and over on our youtube channel
we actually have so many videos that
we're uploading there that go along with
the podcast so make sure you're
subscribed over on youtube as well as
wherever you're consuming this content
on every single week we love to dive
into a topic that's going to help you
grow your youtube channel but today it's
going to help you grow your income and
that's because we are talking all about
brand sponsorships have you ever been
someone who wanted to figure out how do
i get those brands to actually send me
free things but not just send you free
product actually pay to make content
happen how do you partner with them what
do you say are there things in the
contract you should be aware of and what
are some of the mistakes that content
creators make when it comes to actually
partnering with brands over the last
several years we've partnered with a lot
of different brands here at think media
grossing uh close to or over seven
figures close to almost uh multiple
seven figures and through those
experiences we've learned a lot and part
of what we learned are ways that we can
actually increase our prices and someone
who helped us do that was our friend
justin moore he's going to be our
special guest here on the show today and
i'm excited to bring him because he has
such a wealth of experience
working with brands justin moore is
actually a sponsorship coach and the
founder of creator wizard
it's a school and community that teaches
you how to find and negotiate your dream
brand deals so that you can stop leaving
thousands on the table along with his
wife april he's been a full-time creator
for over eight years and has personally
made over four million dollars working
with brands he's also run an influencer
marketing agency for over seven years
that's helped other creators earn an
additional three million dollars justin
actually brings a very unique
perspective because not only has he been
a creator in the trenches doing the
sponsorships for years but he's also run
an agency where he has insider knowledge
behind how the big brands are choosing
which influencers to partner with and
why they pass on others now justin's
mission is to enable creators big and
small to land 1 million paid brand
sponsorships by 2032.
so if you want to jump into figuring how
to do this lean into today's featured
conversation with our special guest
justin moore
well justin welcome to the think media
podcast this isn't your first appearance
on think media you're an alumni now so
welcome back to the show when i said you
need to have me on again i didn't know
it'd be so soon but here i am
so uh we had justin uh on one of our
inner circle trainings which is uh one
of our monthly coaching problems that we
had here at think media and he blew our
students away and we had the most
requests to get justin back on so i
thought no better place than bringing
you over here to the think media podcast
and i'm so excited because we're going
to be diving into how to get your first
brand deal you know i think this is an
elusive things to a lot of creators of
like i know brands can pay me to do my
content i have no clue who to reach out
to how much do i charge there's so many
questions when you get started so we're
going to break all that down today but
justin i want to start at the very
beginning because you know i i talked
about who you are and just the massive
impact that you're having on think media
as well as on so many different content
creators income streams and so take me
back though to really the beginning how
did you even get into being someone who
really understands this brand
partnership world yeah it's a great
question heather so um first of all
thank you i appreciate that and those
kind words um you know from my
perspective like
we
did had no idea what we were doing when
we started out i just want to make that
very clear okay right so it's like uh
you know when my wife april and i
started um on you know she started her
first youtube channel in 2009 so way
back in the day before there was a
partner program before you could make
she got rejected from the partner
program three times so it's not like we
were like out the gates had like a
million followers like we were making
all this money it's like no like we were
just like
the rest of us we were floundering we
didn't know what we were doing you know
early on like we were not being
compensated like when brands reached out
it was free products right they were so
s we were like my wife in particular was
so stoked to get this because she her
first channel was around makeup and
beauty and cosmetics and so on and so
getting free makeup heather makeup's
expensive isn't it right it's like
really expensive and so the prospect of
getting like hair tools and makeup and
cosmetics and stuff she was just like
like mind blown like super excited just
about that and so
that was like where we lived for a very
long time it wasn't just like oh we got
a bunch of you know free but it was like
years years of free stuff because
remember this is 2009 2010 2011 early
early days of youtube and social media
brands really did not get it like they
were that was not like let's go pay
content creators let's go pay youtubers
to like talk about us for them it was
like
in the early days we were you know had
no idea what we were doing and so we
would talk yeah free products send it
over sure we'll link it we'll do all
this stuff right and so like the brands
they were seeing all these sales they
were seeing you know like we yes we
could see you know amazon associates
like revenue and stuff like so we
definitely could see that but it wasn't
like people were compensating us like
flat fees to like talk about them quite
yet right and so like for them the
beauty brands i will give them credit um
versus a lot of other types of of
industries they saw the direct
correlation early like they were just
like we send this person free stuff they
talk about it and we make a bunch of
sales right so it's like to them it was
like they got it and so it was it was
that was the those early conversations
were um you know it was yeah we still
had to do education but eventually they
were finally like okay yeah we'll pay
you a hundred dollars and we were like
yeah so we were so stoked right like we
were we were so excited because i was
like you know in the early days we were
young we were you know in our early 20s
like just graduating college essentially
so like
a couple hundred bucks was like super
meaningful to us it still is super
meaningful right that's like your car
bill or your groceries or like whatever
like your phone bill it's like very
meaningful even today right and so the
first thing i'll say is that yes like
you know early on when we were creators
i've been doing this a very long time um
i just want to say like it's really
important to like i am a big big big on
not like being so hard on yourself with
this type of stuff because like
you know it's not like you could take a
class about this like in well now you
can take my questions
or you can't there's no college classes
there's no like none of that you want to
watch some youtube videos or something
but it's like not like there's like
certifications or degrees you can get in
this type of thing
and a lot of us like you know probably a
lot of us listening to this are
starting to make an income potentially
making a career for ourselves in this
space right um and so that's the first
thing i want to say is like
if you're a creator listening to this
don't be so hard on yourself like we
even us we made so many mistakes over
the years you know you name it like you
know
one in particular was like i remember we
gave brands uh we turned on the tv one
time and we saw my wife's face
a clip from one of our youtube videos in
a tv ad and we were like we were like uh
did we let them like grant them the
rights to do that let me go look at the
contract oh yep we sure did just for
free products you know so it's like we
again we'd like we've made every mistake
in the book and so um you know a lot of
the knowledge and now i'm like educating
creators around this whole process was
from painful mistakes that we made along
the way and me just being like you know
i just don't want people to make these
mistakes anymore but then the other
aspect is just that i have also run an
influencer marketing agency for many
years also on the other side of it it
was like i actually have now hired
lots and lots of creators to actually do
campaigns and paid creators like hey go
talk about this brand who was like our
client uh it's just like a totally
different perspective and so that's
where i come to it it's like you need to
be professional you need to be
communicative you need to be responsible
this is a business transaction when you
are working with with brands and
advertisers and so i kind of have these
two different perspectives and that's
that's kind of what i bring to my
content
so good and actually one of the reasons
why i geek out on your content justin
yes i am part of the creator wizard uh
community do you have a name for the
creator wizards is that what we are just
creating
well
i i would say i don't have a name i did
can i let me show you my new merch
though hold on okay
well we don't have a name either you
know i was thinking if you're if you're
on the podcast you can't see this but
it's just i have these new hats that say
monetize how dope is that so i was
thinking the monetizers i don't i
totally made that i don't know
i am a monetizer then and one of the
reasons justin why i wanted to bring
your expertise to the podcast is because
not only are you a creator who if i can
be humbled about your numbers have made
multiple hundreds of thousands of
dollars from brands right and i mean
we're talking multiple like let's be
let's be real but you've also done
you've also helped other creators
understand how to do this and i think
that's where your specialty has been so
valuable for what we've even experienced
here at think media like you said no one
teaches you these types of things as
you're starting to grow your brand
you're starting to grow your youtube
channel your personal brand is starting
to explode so i want to start with going
back to uh that beginning first deal you
know we have a lot of content creators
who um we teach them how to grow their
influence on youtube how to start
monetizing using the youtube partnership
program but then there's a lot of
content creators who are ready to start
making those brand partnerships what
does it look like and and let's let's
start from the beginning of like how do
you even find brands that you want to
work with
it's a great question okay so uh the
first hair that i would split about your
first deal is whether you're the one
pitching right so you're actually
reaching out to a brand and saying hey i
want to work with you versus you getting
an unsolicited inquiry into your email
inbox right maybe you put your email
address in your about section on your
bio or your you know about uh tab on
your youtube community or your youtube
channel right so it's like that's the
very first and most important
distinction to make because
in my experience actually it's the the
latter that
happens to most creators it's like they
don't actually be like i'm not big
enough i can't work with brands so i'm
not gonna go reach out to them right
most people it's just like oh my god i
got this email like what this brand
wants to work with me like i don't know
what the heck do i do i don't know what
to say i don't know how to negotiate i
don't know blah blah blah right and so
like let's talk about that one because i
think that that's more frequent right
where it's like i got an email in my
inbox what do i do now i actually have a
video on my channel called a brand email
me now what right because this is this
is the thing that happens oftentimes
right and so there's a couple things
that you need to to remember here which
is that number one
you have to respond okay you can't
ignore it i can't tell you how many
creators i've talked to have just been
so intimidated by the whole process that
they literally just delete it or ignore
it and that blew my mind when i when i
first heard that but i can remember back
to when i was you know we were starting
out that it's intimidating i totally get
that but the first and most important
thing you need to do is just show a sign
of life respond hey this is super
interesting i'd love to hear more just
as something as simple as that just
responding in a timely fashion ideally
within six hours ideally you know max
within 24 hours though would be great if
you could respond and just say tell me
more okay that's it right and then allow
them to
tell you more about the opportunity you
know is it going to be how many videos
is going to be an integrated video if
it's going to be a dedicated video like
just let them talk right um and that's
the first step is because to some degree
it is a uh a fact-finding mission you're
kind of a detective you need to like let
them talk a little bit right if if
you're comfortable
hopping on a call that would be even
better if they come to you and be like
well we'd love to hear your perspective
and you'd be like okay let's just like
get on a zoom and like hash it out right
um but i get it that might be a little
intimidating as well if it's your first
deal um and so
the biggest like perspective mindset
shift i would have around this this
thing is that you are going to make
mistakes like it's not like you're
you're going to be flawless for your
very first deal and accepting that i
think is really important because then
it gives you kind of the freedom and the
liberty to be like okay this is kind of
a test run right i just want to see what
it's like interacting with the brand
they're going to send me the product i'm
going to make some content i'm going to
you know maybe they're gonna give me
some feedback some edits on it i'm gonna
post it yeah i'm gonna make a few
mistakes here and there but i'm gonna
learn from it right and that's like the
most important tip that i want to give
about this first question is just like
don't put such an immense amount of
weight on this very first deal that
you're doing because
believe me what you don't want to do is
screw up a partnership with your dream
brand okay so it's just like you know
the get get all iron out all those
wrinkles the first time with some of
these you know lower tier brands
so that you can make some of these
larger partnerships down the line uh
work really well
so good all right recapping think media
podcast listeners you have to respond
okay this is number one you have to
respond and i love that you hit that
justin because we uh we were working
with a client and he was like yeah i've
been emailed like six times from these
brands and i'm like
six times you need to respond okay um so
that's number one think media podcast
respond and i love how you said that and
i can really tell you from experience of
of never working with brands and then
working with brands at first you really
don't actually know and when you get on
with them they can actually explain to
you what the campaign is i want to talk
about that a little bit because a lot of
times brands have budgets well actually
all the time brands have budgets and so
what their uh um tasked to do whoever's
reaching out to you what they're tasked
to do is spend this budget money and
they're spending it on influencers and
you've been selected as one of those
influencers now i will say justin there
are scams out there so you want to make
sure that you are getting you know it's
legitimate
if it's a business it's a business
that's what i always tell people you'll
know the difference between a
non-business and a real business
but
you want to um you want to hear their
ideas talk about that for a minute
justin because i know you really have an
insight in the idea that this is a
cyclical thing for brands to be reaching
out to creators so if you mess up the
first time you could be on the cycle
again right
absolutely i mean i think that this is
one of the number one mistake that
creators make when they're doing their
first brand deal is they you know the
brand reaches out and says you know well
how much do you charge for a youtube
video or something and the creator says
uh 500 bucks they just make something up
right i get it you don't know in the
beginning right but instead of saying
that use this magical phrase you say
tell me what the goal
of this campaign is
what is success to you
and they may tell you something that's
very surprising so for example perhaps
they say to you well you know we really
just love you know your content it's
super high quality we love you know
you're right in our niche um and
we actually just really want to like
repost your video on our youtube channel
or we want to embed it on our website or
something right which is very different
than like we want you to talk about us
on your channel and we we're hoping to
drive sales from the link in the
description box that's a very very
different partnership and if you hadn't
have asked that you probably would have
pitched well one integration is this
much and you know this type of thing
right but by simply asking it that very
easy question you can completely change
the dynamic of the relationship now you
can pitch them well maybe i can create
some content for your youtube channel i
don't even post it right and that's
going to be probably a lot more money
and the other thing that's really nice
about that is that now your rate is
completely detached from how many
subscribers you have
right or or what your viewership is like
right because that's not what the point
of the campaign is is that you're
actually creating you're like free a
freelance content creator for them right
the other thing to like really important
thing to remember is like put yourself
in the brand's shoes okay
if they are not hiring you to help them
create content or spread the word for
their brand
what are their alternatives well they
could go out and they could hire an
agency right they maybe could hire a
full-time employee to create the content
for them
these are all things that are quite
costly right so um i don't encourage you
to say oh hire me because i'm so much
more cost effective than these other
things but it's just like very important
to have that mindset of like don't like
shortchange yourself right like 50 bucks
is not an adequate level of compensation
for
the work that you're putting in editing
the video shooting it like
doing all this pre-production and all
this stuff right like no you have to
value the you know you have to
understand the value that you're
actually providing to the brain and so
just like putting yourself in their
shoes can be very helpful on your first
brand deal to understand that you are
worth actually quite a bit more than you
think
well i hope you're getting value out of
today's featured conversation and i
wanted to let you know that if you're
someone who's trying to figure out how
to do youtube maybe you've been thinking
about starting your channel but you're
just not ready yet well today is your
day i want to invite you to a free class
that i have called the how to get to
your first 1000 subscribers on youtube
make your first 1 000 without fancy
equipment years of editing experience or
50 hours a week to spend on your youtube
channel i have a free class you can go
to at thinkmasterclass.com
to get signed up today to be a part of
this creator revolution there are over
425
000 full-time content creators happening
right now and you could be the next one
but you've got to figure out how to get
to your first 1000 subscribers to be
able to unlock a lot of those monetary
benefits so if you want to figure out
how to make some extra cash in this
season with your youtube channel then
this is the class for you you can sign
up at thinkmasterclass.com
and i'll see you over on that free
on-demand youtube class well let's get
back into today's featured conversation
with our special guest
so good all right that was a
review piece i wanted you guys to listen
to tell me what your goal is that is so
good because it does reframe even what
the conversation is and that actually is
one of the best negotiation tactics to
even know where the starting line is so
justin really good on that when you are
helping uh content creators and you're
matching those content creators with
brands what are some negotiation things
that content creators should be aware of
when they're making that content i know
you you said uh you know you turned on
the tv and there's your wife's face how
do we even know in this world like what
what should we be on the lookout for
what are some pieces that you're like
ahaha don't do that uh when you're in
those negotiation phases of creating
those brand deals so i've got a very i'm
a big fan of frameworks okay and like
acronyms and stuff so i love making
making up my own and so i have one
that's actually very
simple and can help you with your first
brand deal which is what i call the do
rule which is d-u-e okay and the d
stands for deliverables if you're trying
to understand the dynamics of a campaign
and they're reaching out to you you have
to understand what are they actually
asking you for right we mentioned at the
at the beginning like is this going to
be an integrated video or is this going
to be a dedicated video those are
actually two very different things that
i would actually recommend you should
probably be charging two to three times
the amount of money for a dedicated
video that's talking all about this
brand or this product right um and so
deliverables you have to a lot of times
brands will reach out and just be like
oh we just wanna do a couple of posts
and like collaborate no how many posts
is it gonna be two or three videos like
that's a big difference right you gotta
tell me right so that's the do rule
that's the d and the do rule the u is
one that a lot of creators don't think
about which is the usage rights okay and
what this is that what does the brand
actually want to do with your content
beyond you posting it right because it's
one thing to post it on your youtube
channel but do they want to embed it on
their website did they want to post it
on repost it on their youtube channel do
they want to run like youtube ads with
your content
and if they do for how long do they want
to do it is this something that they're
going to be running for five years right
where in essence you're gonna your name
and likeness as they call it is gonna be
tied to this brand or this product for a
long time so it's something you
absolutely need to be asking about and
charging accordingly for and then the
the e in the do rule is exclusivity
right are they actually going to be
asking you to be exclusive to their
brand or their product or their service
for a certain duration because you know
there's an opportunity cost associated
with that if one of their competitors
you know approaches you six months down
the line and you signed a one-year
exclusivity clause um then that's gonna
be challenging right um and so that's
like a very simple framework to use uh
when it comes to trying to scope a
potential partnership and all of those
factors you need to consider
okay so content creators i hope you were
taking notes during that because you're
gonna sound so educated on your first
deal already because you now have the do
framework that is the deliverables the
usage rights and the exclusivity and
this is something that here at think
media we've learned from you justin you
know we went through your class we took
you know the content that you have out
there and because of those things we
were able to double and sometimes triple
our asking costs because of those
specific things they want to use our
likeness they want to use those videos
in other capacities and so we were able
to negotiate additional fees of those
things and increase the budget that we
got from a brand just because of knowing
that do role so thank you justin um i'll
give a tip jar maybe one day uh
absolutely i'm so thrilled to hear it i
love it okay so you mentioned uh
something that i know is always the
sticking points for those first time
content creators and brand deals and
that's the contracts okay no one teaches
us all this stuff um and i know
sometimes that brands are working with
multiple content creators and they do
have the upper hand of understanding
contracts and what's in those what are
some tips you have for content creators
in in one either making their own
contracts if that's what the brands are
asking or two how to really go through
those to know what they should be
looking for in those deals
all right i'm going to give a piece of
advice that may be somewhat
contrary to what other people might
suggest but um i think it's a very very
important thing to understand as a
creator especially if you're you're
thinking about doing your first brand
deal which is that
i believe that you should go out and
hire a lawyer
to create a contract template for you a
boilerplate contract template for you
where the only thing that you change is
maybe the last page which is often
oftentimes called the appendix and the
only things that you're changing about
the deal are the deliverables right the
usage rights the exclusivity you're just
like putting those in there based on
whatever the brand is saying
and then you have that document that
boilerplate document that's kind of been
blessed by a brand uh or blessed by a
lawyer to be able to utilize if you need
to and the reason that i'm saying that
that's so important for you to do now
even if you do not have a deal in hand
is because this is an investment in your
creator business if you were starting
any other business if you were starting
a brick and mortar shop there are costs
of doing business right you have to buy
the ingredients you have to hire
personnel you have to do xyz for some
reason a lot of creators be like oh yeah
i'll buy a new camera or i'll buy new
editing software or a new laptop or
whatever that's an investment in my
business but hiring a lawyer to like
have a you know protect myself
like in the event that i'm going to go
partner with brands somehow that's like
no i'm gonna wait until i get a deal
that like just because i get it right
like sometimes you know the deal is not
a ton of money maybe it's 200 bucks or
300 bucks or something and then if you
have to hire a lawyer well there goes
all your profit you pay them for a
couple hours and you're it's a net loss
but like no this is an investment in
your business so even if you do not have
a deal in hand i think it is a prudent
thing to do as a creator to like inves
if you want to actually make an income
doing this being a creator this is one
of those investments just like all that
other equipment that you love buying uh
to you know formalize your own business
i love that reframe because you're so
right we are easily uh drawn to the
shiny object of the new lighting or the
new thing but it's kind of that back-end
business stuff that gets left behind and
i can tell you from knowing content
creators who have had their likeness
taken who have had uh content who have
who have literally done the work for
pennies that they could have been really
making substantial income i know justin
you've worked with content creators who
have because they've taken the right
steps of understanding how to do this
right have made massive income from
understanding brand deals properly right
100 and i think that um
maybe this will be the point of the
podcast where there's a little friction
flying heather but um i i actually have
a very controversial stance which is
that
you can actually make way more money on
sponsorships than adsense
over the course of your career as a
creator i'm living proof of that with my
wife and i's youtube channel right and
so um the reason being is that i
actually here's an anecdote i saw a
pretty prominent creator uh share on
twitter recently that in the lifespan of
their uh youtube channel um you know
it's like more of a micro micro creator
but like pretty prominent in their niche
um they've made seven thousand dollars
on youtube adsense over like two or
three years and they just got
one brand deal for ten thousand dollars
so
if you can make a lot of money finding
the right brand partners in one fell
swoop then all of this huge amounts of
energy that you're putting out there to
try to either get monetized on youtube
which absolutely is a awesome goal and
you should definitely have it if you
know as part of your diversified creator
business it's a great income stream but
like i think a lot of creators are just
completely missing the boat and not even
thinking about how much money you can
actually make from sponsorships because
again going back to this whole thing
about the value that you're providing
brands like they have the budgets to
like get content to partner with
creators and get their name out there
and so i think it's just like a very
important again a mindset shift around
like you don't just have to be making
money from adsense there's lots of other
ways in which you can do it
yeah and i want to hit on that point too
because i don't i think sometimes
creators don't see
actually the value that these brands are
willing to pay for and you know when you
go back to brands are willing to pay
micro influencers that's one of the
specialties that you have justin is
understanding the micro influencer piece
let's go down that path just a little
bit because i i want people to start to
see themselves not as just a youtube
creator but like what market are you
actually impacting and then how do you
get the brands in that market to
actually see you what are some tactics
as a micro influencer that you can do to
actually get brands to see you so the
number one piece of advice i can have to
you know about getting on brand's radar
is to tag them a lot like when you're
posting and post about them on social
media a lot of creators be like well if
i post about them why are they going to
pay me for a campaign and i'm just like
here's how it works let me let me walk
you through it okay when a brand decides
that they want to run a paid influencer
campaign there is often times almost
almost 100 of time there is going to be
some sort of
like promotion that they're running
maybe it's a discount maybe it's the
holidays maybe it's you know 10 percent
off it's you know use your code just in
20 for 20 options first purchase
whatever there's something that there's
a reason that they're running the
campaign
right when you're just posting about
them organically on social media are you
seeing any of those talking points are
you using the promo code are you doing
any of that stuff no you're not doing
any of that stuff because you're just
sharing your authentic affinity for the
brand or the product and so this is like
a giant like
like
mindset shift i need you to have around
this which is that this is the best way
to get on the radar of the brand it's
attack is to you know post about them
and then you know oftentimes maybe this
has happened to you maybe you tag them
on instagram or something like that and
then they you know respond in your you
know stories or whatever oh thank you so
much for tagging me can we repost this
on our on our you know people get mad
they're like oh can we repost this on
our page and people will be like no they
need to pay me this is the perfect
opportunity you have your foot in the
door now you've shown they have shown
you that they value you and your content
now is the perfect chance to pivot this
into a paid partnership and you say oh
thank you so here's a template for you
anyone listening ready for a template
here's a template if this ever happens
to you you say i'm so thrilled and
honored that you like my content so much
that you'd like to repo rep you know
repurpose it that actually uh you know
requires an investment i would love to
hop on a call i have some other unique
ideas that i could share about new
content that i could create for you in
addition to that are you free on
thursday at 1 pm to hop on a call
that's what you say and here's another
template if they repost your content
without your permission you don't say
how dare you take this down i'm going to
contact my lawyers no you say i'm so
honored that you loved my content so
much that you wanted to repost it that
requires an investment can you let me
know the budget you've set aside to
secure those rights
i'd love to hop on a call at thursday at
1 pm to discuss some other ideas i have
right so you don't go into it indignant
you go into it
viewing this as an opportunity to get
paid
oh i'm just i'm over here just wanting
to jump up and down justin because
you're speaking like a business owner
and if there's one that like quote that
i love so much it's jay-z i'm not a
businessman i'm a business
man and you partnering with brands it's
your likeness it's your content it's the
effort that you're putting out there and
this is a rising economy like if there's
one thing that is happening right now
it's brands understanding that normal tv
commercials not working that normal
advertising not working you know where
people are they're in their apps they're
in social media they're on youtube and
last question that i want to talk about
is the idea of turning one
video into a multiple video uh type
content meaning when you're negotiating
and they're asking for one thing how do
you ask for more like oh is it on
youtube only or do you also want
instagram oh is it like how do you
expand to ask for more money okay so
let's talk about the reasons that a
brand would pay you to make actually
more content okay
so
just like what you said earlier heather
which is that brands have these budgets
and they have to
like spend it right they gotta like pay
creators they you know they have this
budget allocated for them um for this
particular quarter for this particular
month right
so when a brand reaches out to you
they're not just working with you
they're working with probably five other
creators 10 of their creators 25 50 100
other creators sometimes these big
campaigns right and so what does that
actually mean
put yourself in the brand's shoes that
means that they have five 10 25 50 other
email threads that they have to manage
50 other personalities 50 other
contracts that they have to deal with
and so when they come and ask you if you
can make one video
what you are saying to them when you say
hey you know what i know you only asked
me for one but i can actually make five
videos for you in their mind they're
thinking like wow well i can just hire
heather now for this and i don't have to
worry about working with four other
creators for their email threads for
other contracts
he's you know she's gonna make my life
easier okay sounds good i'm gonna pay
heather five times the amount of money
right so it's like it's not just about
like oh let's add on to this and like
let me give you a discount for like you
know no you're not you don't give them a
discount stop giving them discounts
you're not a discount creator okay the
reason that that they're gonna go with
you for these other you know packages
that you're providing to them is because
you're making their life easier okay and
yes there may be some situations where
yeah maybe you wanna you know if it's a
longer term deal or whatever maybe
there's some sort of you know pricing
concession but that's not what you lead
with you don't be like i'm going to give
you a discount if that's the one thing
that you learned from me and my my
content and all this stuff is like like
as a creator stop negotiating against
yourself oh i could nor you know i
normally charge 2 000 but i could do it
for 1 000. like before the brand ever
says like our budget is one thousand
right you're like you're so excited for
the deal you negotiate against yourself
you know you're giving discounts stop it
stop doing all that because you're worth
it you have value stop providing
discounts if the brand's not asking for
it please and so like again when it
comes down to like you know extending
the deal the one final like caveat that
i want to give about this potential
thing is that
it's a lot easier to convince a brand to
do a long-term partnership with you
after they've seen had some experience
working with you on one deal so it may
be somewhat difficult to like convince
them to do a six-month or 12-month deal
with you right out the gates but if you
do one deal you're very responsive
you're very professional the content is
super high quality you know you provide
a post campaign report which is
something i teach in my course right you
do all these things where you're like a
business i'm a businessman right so it's
like you do all those things then
they're going to be like okay let's
let's hire him for a six month retainer
thing right so it's like i know everyone
wants these kind of like longer-term
deals but it's just the reality they're
not gonna you know they've been burned
too many times from creators who are not
professional who are not communicative
and so like they need to have a little
bit of experience working with you to be
able to justify doing something like
that
so good so many nuggets right there one
don't lower your price okay don't lower
your price and then two be professional
if there's one thing that i wish more
content creators would do in this
industry it's to be a business is to put
your business hat on and think how would
you want to be treated how can you
support the brand and i can tell you
from being the type of content creators
that have gone above and beyond we send
christmas gifts to our uh to our brand
um representatives we know their kids
names like we do that because we want to
be in partnership with them for a long
time and because of being able to be
someone that's professional that offers
those things we've secured brand deals
where they've never paid creators that
amount of money because they own they
know that they can trust us to be good
representations of their brand uh in
that partnership so justin oh my
goodness so many nuggets uh if you want
to uh go deeper with you justin where
should they go how do they get involved
uh if they if they want to know the next
step with you what's the best way to do
that all right well the the top thing
that i would really really really
recommend everyone listening to this to
do would be to join my newsletter
because i literally every single week
it's a free newsletter i sent you paid
sponsorship opportunities in the
newsletter every single week okay so
you're definitely gonna also share like
videos and about pitching tips and all
that stuff so if that's interesting to
you just go to creatorwizard.com join uh
and then yeah i have you know i'm on
youtube tiktok pretty much everywhere
creator wizard and this is all i talk
about y'all i don't talk about anything
other than sponsorships and brand deals
so i know you guys love talking about
you know finding your niche on think
media and so like this is my niche this
is all i talk about so if that's
something that uh you think sponsorship
should play a a role in your business
come hang out we'd love to connect
so good we also have a link for you down
below in the description of the youtube
video or if you're listening over on the
podcast we'll include it in the show
notes we've partnered with justin to get
you some free content that's behind the
scenes so you've got to go there click
on that link and that'll help you get
your first 14 days of understanding all
this content justin walks you through a
whole class on exactly how to set this
up what to do how to pro how to approach
brands all the things happen so make
sure you click the link uh if you want
to go over there justin thank you so
much for your time it is so incredible
to be with a content creator who
understands the business side of it so i
just really appreciate you all that
you're doing to really help double the
creator economy i believe that you're
one of the people in the forefront doing
that and i so appreciate your knowledge
and all that you're bringing to our
audience thank you so much for being on
the show today you're so kind thanks for
having me heather was a blast
wow wow wow i mean
are you ready to get your first brand
deal i hope that there were so many
magical nuggets there for you to help
you figure out how to land that next
deal actually let me know if you're
watching over on youtube have you done
your first brand deal and what was your
experience like i would love to know
that and if you're listening over on
audio right now you can actually drop a
review and let me know the same exact
thing or with my cheeky plug go over and
subscribe on youtube or go to this video
over on that channel as well but every
single week i love to bring to you one
of our think fam community members who
have left a review and raided this
podcast show over on apple itunes or
sorry apple podcast because that is
actually where uh the podcast can get to
more listeners just like you today's
review comes from bordethian and they
said expand your community with great
guidance relatively new to the scene in
the past six months and these have been
great the passion guidance and media is
very useful this week's episode
explaining looking around and seeing
defeat while in this community people
are crushing it as we make the
impossible possible through opportunity
was pulled right from my head love it
well thank you so much for leaving that
review rating our show here um on apple
podcast and we would just love if you
would subscribe wherever you listen to
this audio and have you shared it with a
friend yet do you know someone who needs
to start to understand how to be growing
their influence using youtube
specifically and then turning that
influence into a high impact and a high
profit business i know i'm going to
share this episode specifically with a
friend i have in mind so it's coming at
you um but thank you so much for being a
part of what we're doing here at think
media stay locked in to what we have
here on the podcast we have some
incredible episodes coming your way with
some special guests like alex hermosie
patrickbetdavid gary vaynerchuk and so
many more so stay locked in here at the
think media podcast and we'll catch you
in the next episode bye
[Music]
you